[Applause]
thank you all for joining us we're very
excited this week we're back from Haiti
we're gonna talk a lot about that thanks
a lot and right here we got our JD
Neiman say hello Jay hey everybody how's
it going this is awesome I got a great
new shirt sorry ladies I'm ready like a
brother to somebody else thoughts guys
thoughts on the shirt great is an
exaggeration really great really great
okay
I like as much print as possible on a
shirt and I like to feel it you wanna
feel my shirt now please please okay uh
everybody hate emotes hey your could be
shoes ooh m/e good to see you
I love someone actually hello what's it
going how's it going um today we're
gonna be playing a game that's not yet
it comes out tomorrow it's called Dragon
Ball Z Dragon Ball Fighter Z oh yeah
also I will say it's a little confusing
it's a Dragonball Fighters II or
Dragonball Fighters what do you think it
is I hope it's Dragonball Fighters I
think it's Dragonball Fighter Z they
definitely did that on purpose there I
loved Dragonball Z I continued to love
it I have a number of Dragon Ball Z
figures really I got trunks I got a
Vegeta or vegetto I don't know say his
name I got some Goku of course I got
Frieza I got cell perfect form I've
never seen it my knee quills blowen says
lumberjack yeah fighter Z we're gonna be
playing it today um the bait out you
know I played a little bit of the beta
is super fun but RJ and I are gonna test
our mettle can't wait it's gonna be
awesome
alright so here's the thing there's an
embargo we can't show any the story mode
so we're just gonna battle against each
other which i think is great that's all
I want to do fair enough
so let's do it let's get into the game
so maybe we should view the explanation
it's a kind of mode blah blah blah okay
and there's a large I'll say this
there's a large lobby here I don't know
if you could see you can run all around
and it's a huge this was in the beta and
this is how you kind of this is your
menu this is how you choose what to do
this is awesome yeah it's pretty great
Chris sabot voice of idjit it pronounces
fighters and since I'm team is it veg
Vegeta Vegeta it's Vegeta Vegeta or
Vegeta how do you say that blond red
crazy space man but Greta Greta that's
totally wrong I'm not saying for Greta
ever don't ever say that again for Greta
Greta is what I have after eating when I
get sick off of too many vegetables I
have a lot of vigraha oh okay what I do
any vegetables I have a lot of regrets
okay
prepare for terrible puns the entire
time um okay so here's what we're gonna
do how many players do we want just the
two of us just two yeah yeah well the
thing is you can have computer players
too
can we just start off with with just us
just that's all I mean okay all right I
don't know the community why I don't
know that controls either contra
Virginia okay good who are you like a
brother to every girl I ever meet and
every guy I'm not brother to every but
yeah I'm a brother I returned the lobby
yes okay um
Vegeta Vegeta is it hard JIRA sighs by
the way I don't say gifs I say gifts
what do you say oh I say gif yeah of
course
good say that's terrible that was that's
great yeah definitely give 100% gif if
you say jiff leave the champion right
now hey now go home and think about your
life or if you're at home then just
start thinking about your life okay so
what I wanted to open in battle there we
go all right we can I ask you a question
first
no no you asked me a question is do it
should I use is it better to use this I
use this stick or this I use a stick oh
wow waffle tart says okay bye guys team
Jeff yeah go home
peace sweet alright so here we go yeah
so basically they're all these dudes and
ever heard of the term super Sayan no
okay it's like when you power up and
your hair goes blonde okay cool I'm a
piccolo man myself I enjoy a good
piccolo scare reminds me of megaman kind
of so you choose two dudes by the way oh
and they switch out kind of like the
newer yeah you choose two guys so I'm
gonna choose I'm going piccolo I'm going
team green
piccolo and cell I'm gonna choose three
guys we choose three guys I didn't know
that ago my god how many people by
choosing I'm going mid Frieza let's see
oh but look at this we could change
colors to look at this ooh of this
student freezes it I'm going I'm so oh
wait how are you changing colors up and
down I'm gonna go uh yellow cell oh
you're gonna go blue zoom
this is so great I love this already
beat red Megaman I'm going classic
Frieza that and it looks like the
Hewitt's turned off right white J animo
Super Saiyan sorry super saiyan thank
you guys for helping yet I'm going oh
your ooh you're really making it really
colorful yeah yeah I'm trying to be
colorful alright okay team rainbow let's
do it hit X
soon well it kind of looks like cloud
city over to the right yeah god you're
obsessed West City yeah half the name
plus I mean I guess if City was the
thing select music auto team green
immediately removes the green from one
of the character so Jeannie baby alright
so I think how does this work
I don't know alright we're gonna find
out I will sales yeah their combos
fighting what do you mean combos the
snack or combos the app was the snail
there's no commas the snack yeah
by the way best combos where's your
favorite combo oh what's your favorite
combo by four I know wow look at this
piccolo I feel like you're gonna say
pizza combo but I'm gonna say cheddar
with salt on the outside
oh you mean the pretzel pretzel pretzel
with cheddar in the men chatter Chester
pretzels grant I do like Pete I like
pizza pretzel combo okay okay all right
here we go oh it's giant baby look at it
you are a giant baby about it butter how
great is the animation oh this is Amit
whoa what is that
have a little fireball [ __ ] yeah
oh she Oh are you doing I don't know I'm
just trying to figure out some combos
Jesus
my god you're kicking my ass oh my god
oh oh oh yeah just swish the freezer
I don't know if that's hurting me or
hurting you oh you know what
Oh cells gonna Oh owning you bro yes
get out of here I can't even do anything
what does that do it does it's uh it's
your farting I think I don't know what
it does
oh [ __ ] you know if you hit both
triggers or both top buttons you call in
another guy this is awesome is this
great I don't know what I'm doing it
it's awesome yeah it's so clean one of
the best fighters in a long time agreed
this is like a beautiful beautiful game
you've got some crazy dude you are like
oh my god what was that moon I'm calling
it somebody else help me but oh so Oh
how'd you do that
I've the two top buttons oh yeah I'll
kill torn your dude time to switch guys
oh I love that
oh sweet kick oh my god
Jesus Jesus oh my god
the levels cool - yes let's go got my
boy piccolo back oh do the great hey
sting with Sun you're saying you want to
say hi to the chat written here see how
to chat pop on distract them eyes best
dressed man on the show
show them your shoes show them your
shoes destroy this dude Marshmallow Man
March down backwards r1 where's that
down backwards r1 it does oh yeah it
does you weirdly
damn straight Frieza what are those
let's see them kick not on-cell love
those shoes so clean says Madeline
Simpson I'm genuinely depressing we will
play this i pre-ordered a month ago it's
ever played what about the Oh could
compare to its roller right yeah it
comes out tomorrow Aaron you're a major
nerd you don't know Dragonball I kind of
know flip I know a little bit gasps I'm
sorry I did not put up a good fight so
the idea of vest loafers agreed so
basically the idea so somebody explained
with Dragon Ball is I can't explain it
well basically they're these Dragon
Balls and you get them all you get to
like it grants you any wish
it's like Pokemon no man it's not like
Pokemon it's not at all like poke you my
has nothing to do with Pokemon right
let's do it let's do a quick another
battle and then we do a tournament right
all right cool all right pick up with
house I'm gonna pick some other guys
yeah yeah and then so you've got so
basically like there was this this
doctor I don't know the name doctor the
doctor guy but he made so the doctor
made she's an Android and so is this
dude these Android 16 and her at 17 and
then the doctor got killed and then cell
came back from the future and to suck up
the androids into his tail and then he
became this perfect form cell and he was
really hard to beat so basically the
good guys are like you got your Krillin
you got your Gohan I I don't know who
that is I don't know that is and they're
all on the side of good wait wait so in
the show do they just fight each other
yeah basically they fight all the time I
don't know this guy's either colors here
red I'm gonna go Gohan as a team I'm
going all red team red oh man go tanks
I'm going all Gohan's
all Gohan's I'm going Gohan adults I'm
going
Gohan as a team this is gonna be like
this is us but like Gohan's
you know who's this dude never seen that
guy and then whoa no is Tracey hair go I
love trunks where's trumps think I don't
think Trucks is in here oh and if you
Lock drones trust my favorite dude he's
got a sword yeah we're going team purple
all purple yeah team purple baby I guess
this is good enough
I may be team red do not seem real
you're team red
I'm gonna go team team blue stink sighs
team blue team blue it is I do it sting
said whoops Sky Blues a great color it
is what's my color this year that I
should dress up as all in today sky blue
I think so
team red Astro team register your eyes
well how did you get trunks I need to
see trunks on there
Oh truck sits down there do ya I love
trunks trunks is the bomb
trunks is the son of Vegeta and the
woman he easily is the coolest shoes
that's why I picked it baby team Gohan
and trunk star go tanks oh okay
pre-flight arc says listening to Aaron
explain Dragon Ball hurts hit X and X
DBZ came out way before avatar let's
chooses the space play legit the moon oh
yes base
I just straight-up space they don't it's
not yeah like space what should we name
it space space oh yeah Vegeta and Bulma
made trunks and trucks came from the
future to come back and kill cell I
think yeah worst Dragonball summary
remember somebody summarized it that
Alan Alan Fox summarized it somebody get
it summarize it for us alright
by the way red team and blue team they
called it red team and blue team really
oh look at this oh oh dude go to the
game yes
oh the beginning that the intros are so
dope this is sweet oh boy
these look like two actresses you meet
like in a bar my neighborhood oh there's
[ __ ] floating around bring it girl
well those oh I just splitting the two
people dude yeah all right come on how
do I block whoo I got kicks for days
how about a little fire scarecrow
hey I'll stop to you guys Jesus I'm
gonna pretty up that face with my foot
oh snap bringing in the other guys
brought in trucks and I still kicked his
ass Oh what happened there I don't know
a magical dragon pooped crystal balls
that cause unnecessary strife like oh
dude
damn how's it joking there we go
bring in sonic arts like knuckles I
can't dude his face oh my god he's got
dope ooh he's like spinning around
hitting you this hair yeah
nobody in this nobody in this world
bruises after get a hint like a thousand
huh no no bruising or bleeding
this guy has dope hair mousse hashtag
hair moves Auto combos can be toggled on
and on
I know burning typhoon you should know
us better than that
wait Auto Oh what no oh my god I did
that by on one move it was the best how
did that not just kill you immediately
no this is yours oh I spit out a bunch
of myself
oh you killed you killed on you killed
sweet uh it does st. st. seven it does
have a story mode but we're not allowed
to play it because of the embargo it
doesn't because this game doesn't come
on til tomorrow student blocked it I
blocked it clearly not my god how did
you do that down back our one two years
- I'll do one that's all mine does it
that's is I think oh now it's on bro how
many oh my god you're kicking my ass
dude team red is killing
[Applause]
I just like bitch-slap here's a deep
ocean I love my boobs dude this game is
so epic
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god she's ridiculous get my boy
get Oh Oh God he doesn't do it doesn't
do anything oh there we go
nails that me oh oh I gotcha
barely boots look at the command list
you do down back are - oh you have to
have three numbers down
got it got it so I think yep your bar my
bar has to be full team blue that was
awesome
what do you see your level three special
you do level up Steve Knapp per
character I believe oh I see
all right we'll say pancakes I just said
it there you go all right so Dragon Ball
Z is an action anime show about various
martial artists as they go on adventures
to protect Earth from aliens gods
androids and more but usually it's about
Goku and Goku's this what's going okay
that guy he's like the main guy
yeah he's the main guy that's a pretty
against game this game is amazing I need
rachel10 gooses I need my meter to be
more full I'm not sure I see character
selection should we start a little uh
we're about half done with it so let's
do it maybe tournament yeah yeah we're
doing a tournament maybe sure
which means we're also are we on the
same team I don't know we could give me
fighting computers though so we're not
gonna be good hopefully they're worse
than you let's go Koo it's about seven
dragonballs and wishes down forward our
two works - oh don't forward are - oh
are two down for it are - okay yeah Bo's
pro bozo Pro that's how go coop that was
Goku O's go hon way go on and Goku are
brothers right
oh my god everybody's gonna hate me for
this everybody's gonna hate me
alright sixteen players so it's gonna be
cute it's gonna be two players well this
is for our turn oh oh how many DP is
four four plus four four four computers
yeah all right CPU strength
okay time limit normal one match to win
single elimination or double let's do
one
alright see how I'm gonna do CMD select
character I think you can go every match
okay cool
it's like started position every match
alright let's do it so we play each
other well we could switch it up switch
it up so just in Cait we give each other
a shot here yeah all right there we go
whoo I get a bye to the second round I
know that's you I think you're second
player I think I mean I'm your first
player I think all right [ __ ]
whatever oh no we're gonna watch you
beautifully yeah this is dope oh we
didn't want to play all right computer
gets a bye all right this is like my old
Ken Griffey junior baseball game we just
watch the bracket go right exactly
all right wait can you go to the left
now I can only go well give you a bye
we'll give you a bye all right here we
go
can I get you Sharon Stone's number no
captive quiz I can't Aaron loved the
episodes of clueless came here and we're
thought out the best in this series
thank you so much
that's very nice JP Cajun very nice all
right whose should I be guys I've never
seen this cat guy yeah yeah definitely
the cameras we never used the cat guy
basically this is by the way this guy's
name is what you say at a bar birra
serious yeah hey that table over there
can you hear us can you wear his hat
he's a dope hat whoo I don't know should
I be just dude yeah man
she gets a pick more guys so you pick
three every time okay so who else
whoever I played yet I'm played trucks
is awesome of course oh this is go COO
this is Super Saiyan Goku yeah yeah what
about that alien guy in the middle are
yousa yeah I played freezer before I
hate it have you played we played
Android 16 no I don't think so the
Android 16 and what about who the hell
is this dude hit Goku Black is the evil
Goku Goku black try there's no one's hit
there's only there's only a certain
amount of time a show can be on the air
before like they're evil main character
comes out we're gonna team green on that
green team for sure green team for sure
oh yeah I like his game yet
ohit's an assassin for another universe
alright called hit little on the nose
you ask me beerus looks hilarious what a
beerus takes char by licking himself
beerus is the god of destruction ooh you
know what beer is the god of destruction
I want to see beerus is downright our
one move yeah
beerus just stops in the middle and just
licks himself like a cat
it's disgusting whoa yeah I love this
here we go baby I got a fight against
trunks damn it
do you think there's an English mode
were they talking to me I hope not cuz
they get a show huh yeah oh it's not no
okay alright here we go baby oh you
gotta beat this guy dude yeah I'm
getting my ass key so we can play what
does this move by the way Legos Lakes oh
now it's on
dude beerus doesn't care about anything
beerus is getting his ass beat he's
gonna latin i'm change it change it out
you blushing yeah what's that
he makes like a darn ball yeah it's
found him into the ground
oh yeah did you run it out of life here
oh I got killed huh [ __ ] yeah bring it
injured 16 oh yeah
who celebrates Oh now in the comics cell
kick my ass really yeah because he like
he eats us looks like he might do that
here jeez
good god man I cease I'm just slow this
guy's too slow he's got to get a lot of
good throws though oh yeah
Slayer dart says how come Beth is
dressed up and looks like RJ you caught
us Beth is actually working on Haiti
stuff our Haiti show airs well there we
go
saturday Saturday at 10:00 on TBS we're
in primetime
it's very excited I need to switch out
guys oh my god switch on guys dude oh
here we go
hit alright hit let's see we can do hit
we need something big here dude mean a
big move hit we need a big move on
by the way the computer is really there
we go whoa
there we go
Oh a blocking mask
sell is really good
I love that you're in this like Stadium
and there's a restaurant right behind
you in the middle of the stadium
here we go
see he's he had more guys I couldn't
stop I did pretty well though man
I gotta win Oh press and I don't know
maybe all right you got to go big man I
got knocked out of the tournament I'm
out I gotta win the sir it's just you oh
that was tough
here we go man you're our only hope so
good luck gonna win is it why does that
tack I come ChaCha's I tried but I
always got blocked
Super Saiyan Marcus what's up all right
can i play Ark survival on Xtreme maybe
med dead let's go I think you want to
you know my I think my problem was I
think Android 16 and hit are pretty slow
and I think you need beerus i think
would be good but it's the beerus seems
like a skill guy like you need like it's
very there's a lot of finesse with beers
this guy's we're gonna be team yellow
[Music]
team yellow I like team yellow yellow
they say if you paint a room yellow
you're more likely to fight here in that
room yeah I just need to send a quick
text Conan is asking me to come up to
his office and I have to say no because
I'm doing this yep
[Music]
[Music]
dude that guy's got a lot of veins in
this forehead you might want to see his
doctor for a hypertension yeah I'm in
trouble Casey s I get in trouble every
once in a while I know that's what I
said tutor me see I said he's in he's
welcome to come down here and stream
with us he's in this segment meeting
right now and so I was supposed to go up
and shoot something with him practice
everybody but I'm busy with you guys
YUM Yama Yama Yama chow is the best
someone's saying captain ginyu can oh my
god captain ginyu is ridiculous but
shoulder-pads what is this like the
eighties Mike didn't you get with it oh
my god come on bro try it oh yeah 14
hits oh you got this I believe in you
man oh nice yes dude you're awesome at
this game by the way dude maybe you're a
Super Saiyan yourself super saiyan RJ oh
god oh damn beerus is a dick if you know
how to use beerus well I feel like he's
a pretty big deal oh yeah he just
destroyed through a volcano no it's on
Team yellow dude you got to represent oh
this game is so epic kinda cool gets s Q
please give advice on how to get a job
in a late-night comedy show I got my job
and most people here got their job is by
being intuitive it's kind of like the
minor leagues I know my friends who work
at Colbert The Daily Show all got their
jobs via interning first otherwise if
you want to be a writer I would say get
a manager or agent and submit packets
that way because you can't submit a
packet without a manager agent and she's
about to [ __ ] own you
yeah she owned you oh they're all here
now they're all just teaming up on you
you got oh nice yes sweet but yeah
that's the way to do it internship or
[Music]
maybe he's coughing up like a hairball
there Oh Android up 21 is also unlocked
your story about there we go awesome
Slayer Dart
no that is RJ works at the Kona code
Cummings development company that was
awesome ah
Rowi herskovits is our head music yes oh
wow that was terrible yes nice dude
got him you are a natural at this yeah
dude fry his face off fry those dumb
shoulder pads off oh he got you he got
me I need my backup all right I was most
excited for this guy whoo yeah to
pogo.com slash interns as a slash jaw is
it / - 30 slash jobs are oh wow oh this
oh that's you dude you have a
weird-shaped head know how to say oh yes
Hockley
yeah oh my god this game is awesome RJ
is so good at Dragon Ball Z you are oh
my god kick her ass dude you got this
you got this [ __ ] kick Heather's ass
[Music]
yes no no well we don't one second day
one no I lost
heather's Mean Girls Club beat you're a
spittoon you put up an awesome flight
he's amazing
that's amazing oh crap I feel like my
brain is like growing a tree and the
visual effects are unbeli drug trip
alright hit hit X there so we don't get
to watch that kind of stinks we don't
get to watch them fight you don't know
who's hanging oh we don't at all maybe
they'll let us watch then battle maybe
we still get to play you see this is a
critique they this is a criticism they
should let you watch the other battles
maybe that's a setting I agree this is
so boring kcs Hobbit RJ has come over to
my house for dinner in a video game we
played The Last of Us and maybe tha yeah
the last of crust you can find that on
my twitch channel we made pizza from
like actual pizza dough from Reno's from
Rodino pizzeria which is right over here
and there were Berbick yeah let's do
another tournament that was awesome yeah
it was cool there may be an option you
set the tournament uh I don't see though
I don't see the let's do it eight eight
of us oh no sorry oh you know what maybe
we just Ajit all the players oh that's a
good idea that's what we should do and
zero but it is fun
I know playing it let's put for it now
let's sleep for four team I mean should
we do eight and and two of them are CPUs
oh yeah sure sure sure sure
so like 600 should be eight and number
CPU should be - yeah right message to
win one time limit normal we haven't
been running out of time yeah okay this
is good
that seems a little odd one Guinea
playing all the way oh you know what no
way we could shuffle it up yeah yeah
what what is that is the most absurd
shuffle I've ever seen one on here this
is insane no that's I might want to turn
down the CPU difficulty you know what
that's a good point that was pretty good
was it all right I feel like we were
close you're close
all right let's go to Z right go to the
left right oh we're playing each other
first yes oh if you preorder you get
ssp goku looks like Street Fighter 5 the
Dragon Ball Z sprite all right I'm going
you know what I'm going I'm going here
I'm going team bald team bald mr. Howie
Mandel team that's all we're all Howie
Mandel fans and we're all gonna be we're
all gonna be you know what different
colors you don't own me you know I'm
going all weird-looking gasps oh all
weird oh yeah team bald vs. team weirdo
I'm an ass dude I'm never gonna read the
part you could switch to English dub oh
you can't go let's go
that's cool you're not the worst but
you're not mid-tier okay fair enough
is this is this 1x know we're play on
playstation team weirdo is also
technically bald ooh that's true this is
an oasis and no they're mad no hair
match huh
hey this isn't on switch to I don't know
if it's not okay
Oh see he's funny these are my favorites
these are my favorite parts yeah I agree
oh my gosh wait who's that
that's the tournament leader oh that's
beerus this guy i want to play as the
tournament
no no that's beer i think thats beerus
is dude oh nothing what is what is block
I don't know what [ __ ] uh tired dude
I'm tired of you kicking in FA slamming
you up into higher and higher
wait hold on can i [ __ ] I can't what was
that he's just talking to you beers this
crazy this guy has no special moves
Curlin come on oh my god I'm getting
owned no no
we're both each other
dami here I come you know oh dude I'm
gonna own you I got three eyes man I'm
better dude yeah I know you're still
really good
what do beerus is it can I do all move
yeah house yeah how's that feel
let's do this Jesus Christ what's this
yeah finally no I don't know what's
happening piccolo is gonna kick your ass
Niccolo do something Jesus Christ
I missed how do I do anything oh no oh
yeah Oh laser me
oh that's a kick to the face oh my god
dude
oh my god I feel like would be a cool
character in this game he was always not
Dragon Ball is the bad guy from Temple
of Doom so oh yeah it gotta be awesome
the Rams head Imam damn it give ya nice
I killed one of your three guys
no you got my first guy no oh yeah I
just switched just hold the direction
you're not facing the block I'm doing
that oh this rope three eyed man is back
I just can't stop beerus because
dominates easily the best player in the
game
oh my god I flew into that one beerus is
oh oh you got here we go now it's on oh
wow yeah Master Fett we don't we just
got this game so we don't know enough
about it yet Pierce is the scorpion of
this game
he's the get over here the easiest guy
to dominate with I do want to look at
the command list at some point I feel
pretty good about that match he is the
god of destruction yeah okay Alex
alright well you beat me there well done
alright so should you play or should I
play now you can play on my I think I
need to who don't want to see you oh my
skill I'm gonna hold me do it yeah you
don't you train a little bit more before
you come back before you come back to me
what a dick yah wait I want to go for
the buttons okay here we go
let's look here light attack medium
attack heavy attack special oh you know
I'm hitting the wrong button oh I've
been hitting X the whole time and that's
why it's not doing anything I need to
hit the other buttons dragon rush is
left and medium attack super dash is H
what is super - mean I don't know what
is H I don't know where H is left and s
IC l AF tan s vanish okay sparking blast
okay okay okay all right okay all right
I guess let's try it all right what
should I do now which say which of my
teenage is heavy L is light
got it master fit I don't know what that
means what should I do all what should
be my team man I say oh man it's a good
question let's go
bruisers yeah all bruisers bruisers here
we go I'm gonna do [ __ ] bruiser team
big dude on them oh yeah all right
bruiser team bruisers oh if you just tap
X you'll do combos all right here we go
switch to the English dub oh how do I do
that I kind of like tap square over and
over says master fit that's why he's
winning I'm trying to do different
things square since everybody knows
where too many tryouts these days just
play have fun oh yeah oh I love this you
like it's got well made a girl oh my god
whoa crash ah look at my stand yeah this
is really a roll you guys are playing at
Arches National Park by the way it is
just literally tap square
dude I'm doing so much better already
baby always hits quit oh I'm down I'm
gonna kick your ass I can't wait to play
you again
now I know to tap square do you been
tapped
nice I got you dude I know your moves
but study when God
somebody said you have to have it really
fast
Kam's this is awesome oh my god
toby shite uh here he comes captain
ginyu big shoulder pads be blocking ever
i'm trying the block doesn't really work
is it just point the other way baby bad
that's kind of cool oh there we go it
turns into the Tasmanian Devil and like
boys you up do you think purple it with
purple skin you have to wear sunblock or
do you think it blocks the Sun ooh
oh dude what's happening oh I just spit
in his face yeah super spit man I didn't
do anything but it oh wait I turned into
my turn to the other guy oh wait but
then I'm beating myself up dude I that
was crazy I took over the I took over
Vegeta all that mckenas camera moves you
just spit in his face and mildly
inconvenient you know what he I can
become him and then go to his girl go to
his girlfriend and break up yeah I like
ruin his life
oh now I'm frightened can you oh wait i
cha change dude it's permanently now I'm
fighting my own guy give it whit it's so
like you know what I'm saying I'm
fighting my own guy but it's taking off
the health of the other character oh
cool oh now you don't have say it's so
weird
seriously though can we stop this fight
and go hike around his national park
just BAM triangle you wouldn't break up
with Paula yeah she is hot and she would
kill me that's true dude i Kate this
dude so much
oh no he's doing what is that I know
it's weird mouth sperms more time you
gotta grab him
oh you try I got a I got a complete man
yes yes swear down boom oh that was
close man world Strongest Slam FN square
and X to power oh my god that was that
was too much I want to play you again
yeah I think sake our next match it's on
now dude
a player gets a bye as US players player
yep I don't want to do that though go
right
it's CPU I think oh it is oh you see you
got a play now you play you sure yeah
I don't know how to I might have to go
all the way back to the menu to switch
oh yeah hold on one sec hold on one sec
okay
yeah can you can you press this can you
press button settings oh yeah I don't
think we can yeah
all right sorry kids sorry ooh Sitia
says if you mash triangle you get a
combo the ends with a super so try
mashing triangle this time all right I'm
gonna go
what's my TV ooh I kind of like juice
with small guys small guys yeah so you
could do your pal beerus cuz i think
he's kind of a small guy all right yeah
beerus is no Pierce is actually huge
yeah we do I do what about you do the
opposite dude beanpole oh she's got a
small oh yeah she's signing small guys
small guys
the core I don't know if he's going to
East in this segment meeting he was
texting me saying he wants me to come up
there and I can't go square with
dragonballs okay whose square all right
top pink guys small that's true you're
in dragonballs by doing square combo
then use another square combo to summon
the dragon oh yeah look how angry is
Super Saiyan missed it's got some great
hair though oh the best what do you
think that is to keep their hair oh this
is what I want my hair to be like happy
to these guys
oh yeah he's super saiyan oh dude it's
on what he found out is always come on
you got this
oh he's bringing in other place to
minutes here yeah oh you're owning him
up
you do it well this is a crazy battle
he's busy beating up on a teenager
you're playing a teenager oh nice
whatever the move over your shooting
fireballs do that oh nice shut him down
bro it's about even
[Music]
ah oh he missed you yes oh good counter
yeah dude oh yes your patented kick him
in the face of thousand times move oh
wow I don't know what that was but I
always go well your life is coming back
big time
oh my god you just regenerated all your
life I don't know how I don't know how
either man is toe when you got a dude oh
that was really bad for you his life in
one hit wow that was awesome got me I
did kick his ass here he comes will pow
look at them hands it's a father-son
match yeah team go arm is stronger at
the time we interesting that was the
x-factor got it got it mash mash mash
you know punch oh nice in the back by
the way
oh dude that oh wow and ends it with a
kick that's what I wanted its f-cell man
sells a dick I think give me anytime
oh no I hate sell whoa Android 80 coming
in hot
Oh in a jeans skirt she's kicking ass oh
yeah nice oh dude that was an amazing
move double up she's dumb and she's fast
oh yeah nice you got him you got him hit
him one more time one more time he's
dead
get it one more time nice that's it boom
nice sell is the best sounds pretty dumb
oh I don't know if I could take them
although piccolo Dabney here for the
years 93 mm carrot cottage cheese go
hands father switch people to regain
life says guy man oh that's a good idea
she's my favorite one now ooh
Oh double trouble almost all almost all
the dragon oh this game is amazing it's
beautiful the combos are awesome it
feels epic the pacing is great 3233 hits
bro handling those great riding boots ah
oh no that's bad actually didn't hurt
you that bad ooh double trouble Oh Mean
Girls holy [ __ ] yours got him go check
see nice elbows right in the crotch dude
dude you got this man it's even coming
back come back come back in the century
man yes
[ __ ] you got him you got him just double
oh wow he's really being a pretty big
dick right now
[Music]
great comeback Greg come back though
well well clam yeah I don't think they
realized seventeen is the dude that
might be true it's somebody new dude I
thought it was a girl that's a guy
apparently wearing a skirt that's a girl
maybe now I mean I don't know what do I
know
stop pressing r1 why I mean that's
they're saying damn it
player versus I layer one more this is
going to be our last match okay we're
not gonna finish out the term you know
time alright so this is for all of you
man
this is we're gonna say this is for the
chamber which lamb for lunch
alright alright tacos tacos alright the
the biggest prize one could ever win is
tacos the only one is a girl someone oh
the woman black hair too dude oh I was
gonna say I'm going with my
tried-and-true beerus you know what i'm
gonna do the same team you're doing
alright how about that this is my team
right here this is my jam you know what
instead of her though I'm gonna go him
alright
I'm doing all Reds team red let's go
baby
we don't know a lot about Dragon Ball Z
playing for all the marbles that's right
the blonde and neuroid marries Crillon
oh my god that's awesome but I thought
she got I thought her and I thought
Android 16 and 17 get killed by trunks I
mean 18 sorry
there we go there we go for the tacos
yeah it would be great to play the
players
Jake don't tell me how to live ooh
beerus i guess i'll destroy you now will
you or will you be destroying yourself
oh [ __ ] a talking cat somebody who's
really high when they made this game
let's go
this is crazy oh wow am i playing the
wrong guy or am i beating you I can't
tell you are definitely kicking my ass I
got blue pants right oh wow
dammit
wow that was quick when you're Ike here
comes selfish boy no
[Music]
oh my god what was that
are you with his finger he said pull my
finger
destroyed you oh you're blocking finally
that didn't work very well
where's that horrible
oh I love that move
oh right in the face he's like poink
yeah look a little I'm getting my ass
beat which I can't even beat beerus dude
it's got a ski jacket on
that's fun
Oh tough now that's a tough shoot my
fist to you by the way
bye-bye beerus comes my boy the big guns
coming in dammit oh [ __ ] no no oh [ __ ]
it's my move
oh yes oh oh
tacos beerus is just two tongues and
theirs is too good yours is too good
agreed madeline Sims this game is
beautiful oh my god well guys thank you
for joining us for stream cocoa thanks
for having us
exactly I love I love cell says I would
absorb the two of you again in a
heartbeat if I still possess the ability
that's my new pickup line for girls I
would absorb you in a second
thank you all for joining us once again
the game is Dragonball Fighters E or
awesome drag it out tomorrow biters
comes out tomorrow super fun epic game
band-aid Namco great job great job
Van Dyne em cut Namco great job making
this game it's super super fun pick it
up
thank you to RJ where can people follow
you thanks for having me at RJ Thiemann
easy easy asperity gaming Phin amen
yeah just on Instagram I'll follow those
dude I think of a journey house I'm
gonna go buy this guy tacos go time and
make sure you watch our haiti show this
Saturday at 10:00 CET 10 9 central on
TBS it's an amazing show we're super
proud of it
we had a fantastic time in Haiti I think
it's gonna be really something special
thank you all for joining us we see you
guys next week see you later bye
[Music]